[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bear that
you'll be fine without hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields Milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists indeed we are welcome to
episode number 47 this one is going to
be the best of the minimalist well
actually just the best of 2016 Ryan I
was thinking about making a a greatest
hits
episode but it's like it's like a band
who puts out one album I feel like we've
done one year of podcasts if we don't
have greatest hits just yet
but maybe we can sort of like look in
the rearview for some good moments we
can tweeze out absolutely and that's
what that's what I'm hoping to do here
today and in this episode so episode 47
is going to be the best of 2016 you're
gonna hear some samples from seven
different episodes throughout the year
you can go back and dive deeper into
those these aren't necessarily the best
episodes although some of my favorites
this is in there it's necessarily some
of the yeah they aren't necessarily the
best answers that we have either these
are just some highlights that that we
really enjoyed so this will jump right
in well dive right into this episode the
first clip you're about to hear is from
way way back ryan episode number two
it's the episode on technology what
these three callers are asking is the
same thing in a different way
it's how do minimalist handle social
media and technology and also sort of
alluding toward the the fear of missing
out yeah I guess you know just to start
with with Jeff's he specifically brings
up Twitter and snapchat and all those
crazy social media outlets that we have
where we have this awesome
that a communication to use and
certainly it can be a great tool to use
but yeah I can certainly be overwhelming
yeah I mean this I think our tools are
only as good or as bad as the person
using them use this analogy before but a
chainsaw can cut down a rotting backyard
tree preventing it from impaling your
neighbor's home or that same chainsaw
can be used to hurt that same neighbor
to chop him into tiny little pieces or
or a can of paint can be used to
beautify your home's facade or you might
use it to graffiti the walls at an
otherwise pristine public park and I
think the same goes for technology it's
it's just a tool you know we can use
Twitter and Facebook and Google+ and
Pinterest and all these other places to
enrich our lives and enrich the lives of
others to communicate express ourselves
and share things that we couldn't
otherwise share as easily or we can get
stuck in that social media Bermuda
Triangle right we can Corrine from
Facebook to Instagram to youtube and
just stay stuck and the meaningless glow
of our screens and may I use my phone
all the time to to photograph gorgeous
landscapes message loved ones map out
directions etc but that's really about
the intention we have and and how we
plan to to use the devices and I think
the bottom line is that it's up to us to
determine how we're gonna use our
chainsaws and our paint cans and our
technology ultimately our tools are just
tools and it's our responsibility to ask
important questions about how and why we
use those tools but of course you don't
have to use all of them and so some of
these people are looking for sort of
tips like how do I identify all of these
things I'm overwhelmed with now Ryan and
I
typically don't talk about depriving
yourself of something we don't think
minimalism minimalism is about
deprivation but you know sometimes it's
okay to temporarily deprive yourself so
you can figure out what truly adds value
to your life and I've gone through some
experiments and in my life I got rid of
home internet maybe four years ago and I
wrote an essay about this the
minimalists calm / internet about my
experience of getting rid of the
internet for one month and I'll tell you
what it was the most productive month of
my life and I ended up never getting
that that internet back and I got rid of
my TV and realized that I was more
productive without that but I've also
done other sort of stoical experiments
deprived myself temporarily of say my
cell phone but after two months without
that I realized that yeah I was using
that cell phone not very deliberately
went but I could bring it back into my
life because there were some things that
really added value to my life and so I
was addicted to the smartphone and we
get we can get addicted to technology
and sometimes it's okay to disconnect so
that we can move on yeah I think the key
takeaway here for Jeff is to ask
yourself that question with each
platform that is stressing you out the
ones that you brought up on the
voicemail you know is snapchat is a
really adding value or is it more of an
ephemeral ephemeral way of pacifying
yourself that's something that I would
ask with each application in fact that's
what Josh and I do I mean we have
Google+ we have Pinterest we have
Twitter and Facebook we have a lot of
help managing that I shouldn't say a lot
of help we a little bit of help managing
those accounts just does an awesome job
with that but we did pick those
platforms very specifically we don't
have a tumblr page that we keep up with
we don't have an app chat chat what are
the kids doing these days yeah so
there's a lot of stuff that we avoided
specifically because we felt like these
class
we had it reached the broadest audience
and we felt like we could not only get
the most value of it but add the most
value with it as well all right and the
next clip you're about to hear is a long
time ago we record an episode on
education it was episode number four of
the minimalist podcast is there a decent
minimalist approach to education well it
depends what you mean by by education I
I think sometimes a formal degree is
important I personally wouldn't go to a
dentist who was a DIY dentist right yeah
if I'm getting brain surgery I hope that
surgeon went to college yeah absolutely
and it's because those systems those
structures are best set up to ensure
that those people know what they are
doing however there are many other times
where it is not necessary to seek a a
traditional degree and so maybe we
should we should talk about about some
of those scenarios when when it may or
may not be responsible or applicable or
appropriate for you to to seek the
traditional route yeah I mean first and
foremost if I was to ever go back to
college which I am totally open to that
one day we had a question on our
tuesdays with the minimalists where
someone asked like would you ever
consider going to college if I did it
would be it would be more of pursuing a
hobby type thing like I'd go for acting
or I'd go for physics something that I
was really interested in or that I
wanted to learn more about but I would
never do that if I was going to go back
into debt that is one thing that I
really hoped and I'm 100% debt free and
I hope to stay that way oh just cut you
off there I think I think there's no
such thing as good debt and and that
that's one thing too to be really
concerned about and we're approaching
approaching continuing our education we
often assume that we have to go into
these massive amounts of debt and if you
have to go the traditional route if
you're going to go to a college well
there's some things you can consider you
can consider a community college
especially for the first
years of a traditional bachelor's degree
you should certainly consider something
that's in state with because the
in-state rates are generally appreciably
lower and you should also consider
finding ways to fund your way through
college while you're going through it as
opposed to taking on soon and dead that
will prohibit you from living the life
that you want to live because you're
gonna be tied to an income that you need
just to pay back those student loans
yeah I was gonna say I would even argue
that like you could go to you could go
to school for free right now even
without spending the money even without
having to worry about the money because
what I was going to say is I am taking
classes online right now just kind of
randomly at my leisure for free they are
on like quantum physics something like
really silly but just something that I
want to go down the rabbit hole a little
bit with and I could do that for free
and get some really good classes and
like right now I could totally have a
decent conversation with you about about
quantum physics and when I say decent I
know you could probably a little bit
less than decent I don't know anything
about it a very one-sided question but I
could also go and learn about quantum
physics or I could go improve my writing
on line there are a lot of different
things I can do on line in a very
non-traditional sense and I mean we have
this this in this infinite amount of
information that is at our literally at
our fingertips right now whether it's in
our pocket or on our computer screen or
wherever and instead we spend a lot of
time focusing on incessantly checking
our emails or or just getting caught in
the Bermuda Triangle of social media as
opposed to using the technology to
enhance our lives to improve our lives
to learn and to grow and and and what
we're really talking about here with
education is I want to grow as an
individual well why do you want to grow
it so you can contribute to the world
around you and the more you grow the
more you have to give and so does that
mean you have to go through a
traditional education setting if you
want to I'm not saying there's anything
inherently wrong with it I don't see a
reason to do it for
for most vocations these days well I
mean let's yeah let's go to to brainy
like talk about her situation
specifically so the one of the first
things that stood out to me she said
that she felt like it was draining her
soul now yes now that to me is a flag
right and that's why she called in
because that's a huge flag this feels
like it's draining my soul I gotta leave
now here's what I would challenge Brandi
to do is to really look at the result
look at her outcome that she is going to
get after going to college she said that
she really wants to be a tattoo artist
she loves to paint she loves to draw is
she taking classes right now for
painting and drawing is that helping her
painting and drawing career or she in
there for marketing if it is for
painting and drawing the question that
needs to be asked is is this painful or
is this uncomfortable and there is a
difference right yes indeed I mean if
you are in pain we know when you're
working out you know the difference
between like an uncomfortable getting
that last rep out and oh my goodness my
shoulder hurts I have to put the weight
down yeah this comfor if we're in a
place of discomfort that is the place
from which we grow absolutely so the
question needs to be asked here with
brandy is do do you need to push through
this discomfort to grow and if the
answer is yes then I would say maybe
consider staying in college if the
answer is no by the time I graduate
college I'm gonna have a marketing
degree that I'm not gonna do anything
with then yeah I would consider maybe
going an alternative route
yeah and that alternative route you know
you mentioned a few things that there's
this stigma of of leaving college well
stigma with who I mean if you're hanging
out with people who are discouraging you
from cultivating a passion because you
really enjoy and are excited about the
prospect of some sort of artistic career
and it sounds like being a tattoo artist
is is maybe the terminus of that for you
and I think that's really exciting if
you can cultivate that excitement turn
it into a passion because it's not
something you've yet passionate
about your you won't actually be
passionate about that brandy until
you're willing to put in the many many
many hours of drudgery so that you get
to the other side you get the actual
payoff of becoming a phenomenal tattoo
artist where you feel just great about
what you're doing and you get excited
about being able to do new work and
while you're in it in the moment
sometimes it may seem mundane sometimes
it may seem overwhelming and you may hit
these these plateaus where you feel like
you're not growing but you have to keep
you have to keep working through that in
order to really cultivate it into a
passion that you wake up in the morning
and you feel good about about doing what
you're doing as opposed to the opposite
instead of the opposite by the way of
pain is in pleasure the obverse side of
the coin is Comfort comfort is the other
side of pain and you know what I can
either feel comfort or discomfort
discomfort lets me know that I'm growing
that's one of the reasons we're doing
this this podcast now is it's another
opportunity for us to grow not
necessarily grow our audience or
anything like that but I would say I'm
not very great at speaking and having
these sorts of sorts of conversations
repeatedly but it's allowing me to build
that muscle it's a long ryan to build
that muscle so over time we get good at
it and if you're still tuning in here a
hundred episodes from now I plan to be
appreciably better at having these types
of conversations the next clip you're
about to hear is from episode number 13
we called this one career
let's talk about a job versus a career
versus a mission and let's talk about
where passion comes into the equation
there so if you can usually tell what's
how happy someone is with what what they
do for a living what they do to earn a
paycheck by how they describe it and the
first thing you'll hear people say is I
have a job where I have to go to my job
or this is my job
and and that tends to indicate that
there isn't a whole lot of passion or
even excitement with what they're doing
nothing wrong with having a job we all
have to pay the bills but there isn't a
whole lot in terms of of passion or
meaning or purpose and what they're
doing
the second thing you'll hear people say
often is I have a career and that's a
step up from a job it's more of a long
term job and I would actually argue that
your career is perhaps the most
dangerous thing that you can have
because it's a it gets you to a point
where you're comfortable but most people
don't find a lot of value certainly a
lot of meaning or purpose in in their
career there are the select few people
who call what they do for a living their
mission and those people tend to be very
passionate about what they do they're
usually pretty excited about what they
do and aligns with their values that
aligns with their personal interests now
let me make a distinction here if you
have a passion that you've cultivated
over the years that's great and it may
not have anything to do with how you
earn a paycheck whatsoever the
confluence of your passion and earning
the money off of that is generally how I
would describe a mission if you're able
to make a living off of your passion
then you have found your mission and
life but your mission tends to align
with who you are as a person and so you
have to ask yourself some some questions
here you know does this align with my
values does this position whatever it
may be and you talked about banking
versus creativity it sounds to me like
it may not align with your does
with your interests and you may not find
a whole lot of meaning in a banking job
and if so now would be a really good
time to consider not going down that
road and in pursuing something else
because once you get into a position
where it you've made something your
career
it becomes very comfortable and as
things get comfortable it's hard for us
to put ourselves and what I call our
discomfort zone and and if you're not
uncomfortable from time to time you're
going to stop growing and careers often
long-term careers prevent us from
growing because on a scale of one to ten
we don't hate the job like I know even
when I had my career for twelve years
back in in the telecom world and
managing a whole bunch of employees I
didn't hate my job there are certain
parts that were miserable but overall I
wouldn't have told you that I hated the
job Brian
now what I would have said though is it
doesn't necessarily align with who I am
but it provides me a comfortable
paycheck I make a good living and it was
a five or six out of ten and that that
place is dangerous because it prevents
us from making the change is gonna be
far more meaningful so as you're asking
yourself some questions jack ask
yourself some questions are gonna make
you uncomfortable what is my passion
does this career will align with my
values can i cultivate this into a
passion and if so can I turn it into my
mission I'm gonna talk about the obverse
of that for a second let's say that Jack
does decide to start a career which you
know we're not gonna tell you to or not
to do that but let's say that you look
you're looking at this career I'm gonna
start this the question I want to be
asking myself is am I going to have time
to cultivate passion am I am I going to
have time to cultivate these hobbies
because if you're getting out of college
yes you're gonna have to find a job
you're gonna have to eventually start
paying back all those student loans you
might have to have a job temporarily but
you can still be very deliberate with
the job you choose you're in a great
position right now to be deliberate with
that to make sure that you're choose
something that allows you to have the
time to cultivate your values in beliefs
and speaking Jack to your question about
do you need to make money from your
passion I'm gonna quote Steven
Pressfield he said the professional has
learned that success like happiness
comes as a byproduct of work the
professional concentrates on the work
and allows rewards to come or not come
so what that means to me is that if
you're truly passionate about something
know you don't have to make money from
it it would be great if everyone in the
world could find a passion and make
money from that and make a living from
that but that is not necessarily the the
end-all be-all for every single person
so don't feel pressure to make money
from your passion in fact I would say if
you if anyone out there is putting
pressure on themselves to make money
from a passion that's a very dangerous
approach because you could ruin what
you're passionate about by putting
pressure on yourself to make money from
it yeah I totally agree in fact pursuing
your passion should be independent of
income the cool thing is if you were
passionate about somewhere you're
thinking about cultivating something
into a passion you can find other people
who do make a living off of that you
know if you know someone if you're
really passionate about training horses
or just horseback riding there is
someone who makes a living off of that
there's no question about that right and
then all you have to do is identify
what's their model what's their template
what's their recipe for earning living
off of it
let me cultivate into a passion first
for me writing is my passion it's what
I'm most passionate about but I wrote
for more than a dozen years before I was
able to turn that into my mission and
make a lot of changes in my life that
allowed me to at least start to make a
little bit of income from it in time and
so I cultivated that passion first
eventually in time was able to turn it
into my mission where I did earn a
living from it but what I still write if
I didn't make a penny from it you're
damn right I would because it's
something that I'm really passionate
about and it's something that will carry
me forward going forward now jack
you mentioned the word cushy cushy bank
job I would tell you to avoid anything
that's cushy a passion is not cushy
passion often involves hard work tedium
drudgery getting past the the parts that
seem sexy or exciting to you and moving
forward to something that is meaningful
meaningful does not include the word
cushy
alright last summer Ryan and I hit the
road we brought our documentary to more
than 400 theaters but 15 of those we
showed up at and we had the minimalism
film tour throughout the summer we were
during that tour we recorded live
versions of our podcast and we aired
some of them on our podcast feed and the
next clip you're about to hear is from
our alive event in Miami Florida it's
episode number 22 first off I would
discourage anyone from jumping up and
saying look at me I'm a minimalist I
mean can you imagine if flashback the
screen gets fuzzy here and it's 2009 and
I've got my tie on and I chubby and I
say hey Ryan I'm a minimalist and you
should be too because you've got a lot
of crap how do you think you would have
reacted to that yeah I definitely would
not have been as open to what you had to
say because I would have felt judged I
would have felt like what do you mean I
got all of course I got like crap like
much money I make yeah why wouldn't I
have a lot of crap I mean that's
probably I would have reacted right and
and so instead of me going out trying to
sell this idea eventually when Ryan came
to me it was eight months after I had
simplified my life or been simplifying
my life I hadn't reached an end point
that was a word to use there before I
reach this end point I still haven't
reached an end point and that feels good
to realize that I'm never going to get
there and and so Ryan came to me one day
and said why the hell are you so happy
and it's because he saw the benefits so
my mom had died my marriage had ended
but I was still working in the corporate
world 70 80 hours a week but something
had changed it's not that I was happy
relative to what I am now I'm far
happier now but I had stopped chasing
happiness I realized that happiness
isn't the point
and the more we chase happiness the
farther away we're gonna get from it see
what the point of all of this was it was
living a more meaningful life and and
defining what that means see when I was
successful in a very narrow sense I was
successful monetarily and I had a job
title that may have impressed a few
dozen people but the truth is I wasn't
successful in the broader sense and and
so by by changing my definition of
success I was no longer chasing the
happiness through the next paycheck the
next promotion the next purchase I was
able to learn that the a meaningful life
would make me happy happiness was simply
a byproduct of living in accordance with
my values and and to get there I had to
figure out what my values were I was
focused on the wrong stuff I wasn't
focused on what was important to me I
didn't even know what was important
anymore I got to that point where it's
like okay happiness is right around the
bin and then you get around the bend the
right around the corner and there's
another corner you're like oh it's gonna
be around that corner and then you never
get there and it's like well wait a
minute what am i focused on I need to
stop trying to worry about being happy
and start worrying about what is
important in my life and so I say yeah
yes at that example but I'll also say
this about about the documentary the the
reason that we really wanted to make
this film is what I said earlier during
the intro is we wanted to find a way to
make minimalism
more accessible because it has for a
while been the Josh and Ryan show and
we've we've shown a bunch of a P other
minimalist in other ways we could but
this was the way for us to say look at
all these other recipes you have Leo Bob
Alta in there with six kids and he puts
us to shame he washes his t-shirts in
the sink still and that wasn't the
lifestyle I wanted to live but I admired
that you also had Colin right in there
he travels to a new country every four
months again not a life I wanted to live
but I admired that it allowed him to
pursue what was important to him and so
I think the documentary is will be a
great thing to share with people but
ultimately you're right the best way to
show the change is to show the change
yeah I just want to speak to his point
of proselytizing I was a Jehovah's
Witness for like 24 years knocking on
doors for 24 years you know how many
people I converted 0 now 1 and with this
journey of minimalism
I haven't knocked on one person's door I
have never forward it or like sent
someone in this advert and said you've
got to read this because you this would
help you we simply started a website and
told our story with no expectation and
people found value on it and ultimately
I would I would you know encourage you
to kind of transfer that to to your life
meaning you know if you see someone who
is complaining about oh man you know way
too much stuff I don't know how to
declutter I hold on to all this just in
case stuff for example you might say oh
you know the minimalistic they wrote an
essay about just in case stuff you might
like it I mean something that speaks to
something that they're already calling
out that they have a problem with but
but yeah certainly you know if you have
a friend who you feel like is a hoarder
and you send them our website they mean
they might very well take offense to
that like who are you to tell me I got
too much stuff so I would look for
little opportunities like that but but
ultimately it is it is living by example
when I saw Josh you know like he moved
him and his wife split up and
helping to move into his new apartment
and he's got this lake nice TV bracket
on the wall that came with the apartment
and like the first thing I thought was
like oh I wonder I think of a TV he's
gonna get this is like a big thing
between us we were always like hey look
at my TV you know look at my TV look at
my three TVs and six months would mark a
couple months my by and I'm like you
know over his partner you gonna get a TV
I may or may not six months goes by
still no TV I noticed how he was acting
different at work he started setting
expectations with our boss like hey I'm
gonna be available from 7:00 a.m. until
8:00 p.m. and that's it and that that's
a lot of hours to give you and which was
like sacrilegious where we were working
at we were on call like doctors except
we worked in retail we weren't saving
anybody
we couldn't even save ourselves yeah so
when I saw those things that's what
really made me say okay josh is doing
something that is making him not just
happier but I saw him regaining control
of his time and and and really doing
good things with his focus and that's
what made me go to me like dude what's
going on with you why the hell are you
so happy lately all right this this next
clip is from episode number 27 about
passion first thing you're gonna have to
do is identify what your values are now
everyone has certain basic human needs a
need for shelter and for food and for
clothing but once your basic human needs
are met then you have to figure out what
are the what are your higher order
values in life what what is most
important to me and so you got the
clutter out of the way for us Ryan and I
identified five different areas that
were our values these higher order
values we just called them the five of
values of living a meaningful life so
first off it was health second
relationships third was passion fourth
and fifth they kind of go together
growth and contribution and so we
identified those are our values and so
when you're looking to pick a passion
you want to make sure it aligns with as
many of those values as possible and
then you can also add your own values
well what are your were your beliefs
what are your own morals what do you
find interesting you said you have a lot
of things that you like David well which
of those things aligns most
significantly with with your values and
also the question is is this something
I'm going to want to make money from a
long-term meaning do I want to turn this
into a vocation if so how possible is
that what are the templates out there
when I was leaving the corporate world
people didn't believe I was leaving it
at first right now I I would tell people
that when I was leaving because I had
this prestigious job title as the
director of operations for 150 retail
stores but that wasn't I I was pretty
good at it and so I I they all assumed I
was going to a competitor and I said
well no I'm just gonna go write
full-time and you know I'm probably
working a coffee shop down the street
just to pay the bills and I just really
wanted to write literary fiction that
was my thing and and so I identified
that as as my passion so when I finally
decided to make that leap step away from
the corporate world I was told by so
many people you can't just go be a
writer
if any if anyone could do that well then
everyone would do it you can't just go
make a living as a writer and I just
thought to myself wait a minute there
are thousands of people probably tens of
thousands of people who make an income
from writing and so that's that's silly
what was happening is people were
projecting their own fears their own
insecurities onto me he's gonna go do
the thing he wants to do I don't feel
comfortable enough in making that leap
and going and doing the thing that I
want to do because of X Y & Z don't let
other people project their fears I knew
that there was a model a template out
there so if you are wanting to cultivate
a passion into something that earned you
an income that's that's great it doesn't
have to it certainly doesn't have to be
that way but if you want to do that find
a template find a model find someone
else out there who has cultivated a
passion
and turned it into an income and you can
certainly find those people there there
are plenty whatever you want to do I'm
willing to bet you there is someone who
does that thing very well and gets
compensated for it yeah you know one
thing that David said that kind of oh I
don't want to say rings alarm bells but
it just concerns me a little bit when he
said well you know I just I have all
these passions and I sit there and I
just think about you know stuff until
you know I'm just waiting for something
to click mmm and that is that is I think
that's the wrong approach and the reason
why I say that is because you know we
have this idea that we can sit around
and I was listed well I got this from
Tim Ferriss I was listening to one of
his podcasts the other day and he was
talking about how people sit around
trying to discover themselves and it's
not about discovering yourself as much
as it is creating yourself and many of
you probably heard this this saying
before discover yourself don't discover
yourself create yourself but what that
means is that you can't journal your way
to a passion there isn't a test that you
can take that's gonna say hey thanks for
taking this test here's here's your
passion you want to be a veterinarian
and that's what you're gonna be
passionate about the rest of your life I
feel like high school counselors try to
do that well they try to give you some
guidance I mean that's what they our
guidance counselors and certainly you
know they want to give you some options
but unfortunately there isn't a test and
the thought behind this discovering
yourself is basically kind of looking at
yourself like a block of ice like well
you know if I read this book then I'm
gonna like chip a little piece away and
if I talk to this one person I'm gonna
chip a little bit more way and
eventually I'm gonna reveal myself and
and and again that is not how it works
instead of looking at it like you're a
block of ice or look at it like you're
you're discovering yourself David look
at yourself like your little ball of
clay and that's it and you have to add
little pieces to that ball of clay and
yes reading a book or journaling or
thinking about it will certainly help
you to start to head or will be those
little pieces that you're adding but
those cannot be the only pieces that you
you add to yourself so what I would say
David is this man
use one thing if you if you have 20
things 40 things whatever it is write
them all down and right away you're
gonna no you're gonna no you're gonna
know that okay I can cross off lacrosse
off this list or I can cross off milk
chugging contests off the list
like I mean they're gonna be some
automatic things that you can cross off
and then if you've got ten left over
even if it is still 20 left over put
them all on a hat and just choose one
and do that one thing and do lots of it
over and over again and you know what
you might fail you might find something
that you you pick up on and you're
you're committing to every single day
and realize you know after six months of
really committing really drudging
through the drudgery that man I really
don't like this and you might fail and
that's okay because I can tell you that
the more you fail the more successes you
have also that is a ratio that holds
true so work towards your passion David
and become an expert at it and this one
is from episode number 28 called debt
the reason that you're having trouble
communicating here is you're both
talking about the what right now you're
talking about I want to get out of debt
or I want to stay at home after I lost
my job or or I want to have these bills
I want to have these expenses these are
the ones we need to talk about the why
why do you want to be debt-free why what
anchors are you removing what will that
free up will give you more time to to
stay at home it sounds like you want to
be you want to stay at home I don't know
if you're a stay-at-home mother but I'm
gonna recommend that you actually get a
job until you pay off your debts right
now your if you're in debt you you want
to be able to tackle that as quickly as
possible but you need to show your
husband why that is so important
financial freedom is going to allow you
to travel more what are your goals how
are you going to get on on the same page
now I know you said your husband says
that well our debt isn't that bad
compared to most people well yeah if you
could pay yourself to most people you're
never gonna be happy in fact I think
comparison just by itself is is
dangerous but compared to most people
most people aren't happy most people are
up to their eyeballs in debt most
people aren't living a meaningful life
and it's not because they don't want to
they certainly want to but they feel
trapped and quite often they're trapped
by this thing called debt and so yes you
definitely want to to get out of debt
and and you're gonna need to have a
discussion with with your husband you
need to get you're definitely gonna need
to get on a budget where you you find a
location for every single dollar that
you bring in and hopefully you'll both
be working to bring in more dollars so
that you can pay down that debt your
budget then becomes a contract with your
husband it's also a contract with
yourself but you really can't start
working on that contract until you get a
clear reason why you want to do this the
what is the intellectual side of things
and intellectual the intellectual side
of things does doesn't explain much in
terms of the why the why is the emotion
that visceral feeling behind why you
want to be debt-free
it's where you're going as opposed to
where you are and just real quick you
mentioned marrow our need want like list
it's a budgeting tool that Ryan and I
have used to to be more aware of the
money that were that we're spending and
so for those people who aren't aware of
the need one like list you can just go
to the minimalists com a slash want we
break it down for you there's three
different categories you put all your
expenses in and I think I think that'll
help other people out as well
yeah Merrill I'll talk about Mariah and
I am so Mariah's Ryan's partner by the
way yes Mariah and I were talking about
her quitting her job this was about
eight months to a year ago and I was
like you know you can totally do this
let's let's talk about getting you
debt-free let's talk about you know
getting a six month salary safety net
put together and and maybe you could
potentially quit your job and that was a
common goal that we both kind of found
that we could both work towards because
we want to be around each other more she
wanted to
do more you know she like she looks at
me and she's like man I want to live
that blog life Ryan I want to like you
know be able to you know have freedom
with my schedule even though we work a
ton
you know our schedule is pretty much
ours to manage so that's really you know
what she wants to work towards is having
having a schedule on her own terms and
she really really wants that so first I
would say Merrill is find something that
you and your husband both really really
want and and use that as leverage to to
pay off debt and to work towards and and
then you know got to a point where with
Mariah I I just one day I was like oh
wow
if she sells her car that would like get
rid of most of her debt already in fact
that was her biggest that I wasn't it
was the only debt she had yeah so I'm
like man if she could sell her car she
would be debt-free oh by the way she's
been making double payments on her car
so then she'd have a few thousand
dollars on top of a you know after
paying off the debt she'd have a few
thousand dollars to put away into
savings and long story short and once
we're and I'm like Mariah you could sell
your car we can go down to one car and
and you can even get there faster and
her initial reaction was no I don't want
to sell my car like car a car especially
in Montana it equals freedom in a lot of
cases um you can get around Missoula
really really well without a car outside
of Missoula it's very very difficult to
get anywhere if you don't have a car so
she didn't want to like give up this
personal freedom but then as time went
on and wasn't that much time just a
couple weeks maybe a month where she
started to realize like oh yeah if I saw
my car I can quit my job a lot sooner so
she literally just sold her car last
week so the job was the pain point there
yeah it was more pain than getting rid
of the car it sounds like exactly so so
she she sold her car last week and
basically was able to put a huge chunk
of change into savings she doesn't have
that six months yet but she will have
that six months
I saved up by the end of August and that
is when she will she will quit her job
so her is a plan yeah so she's got a
plan
so what I'm getting at is is that you
know more I didn't want to give up her
car and then saw the benefits of giving
up her car saw the benefits of getting
you know of leaving that huge pain point
of her job and all of a sudden that
moved her to yes let's go down to one
car now the car that she had it was a
like a Chevy HHR like not a super you
know nice car but it was a nice right I
mean much nicer than my 2004 Toyota
Corolla I think it was like a 2010 or
2012 something like that but it had a
you know you know sunroof that didn't
leak it had um heated pleather see yes
it did have heated seats but it was
awesome so like there's all these like
luxury
you know amenities amenities am I saying
that right yes I had all these amenities
that that she really enjoyed however
once we were able to find a goal that
that that equalled more pleasure than
the pleasure of her car she was able to
kind of turn that corner so find
something that you that y'all haven't in
common if it whether it's you know big
time vacation or whether it's you know
traveling the world for a year or
whatever it may be just find something
try to find something that you both can
work towards that that includes paying
off your debt I totally agree with that
we do things for two reasons either for
pain or pleasure so fine find both in
the situation Meryl fine
the the pain points that are there pain
points for both of you and then find the
pleasure that you are both gonna work
toward together and this last clip is
from our episode titled criticism which
was episode number 33 so let's start
with with the bad side of things in the
corporate world we used to talk about
these the seagulls and so we have an
essay from from our book essential and I
just wanted to read a quick excerpt from
that this essay is called seagulls
criticism is inevitable unless you do
nothing in Port
with your life but whenever you put
yourself out there
whenever you expose your ideas to the
world be it via social media blogs or
business meetings you're effectively
wearing a sign that says criticize me of
course some criticism is beneficial
feedback from people respect helps us
grow other criticism however is toxic
the most virulent example is the cynical
internet troll so we're kind of talking
about that today I think trolls are like
seagulls they fly in [ __ ] all over you
and fly away and they're not informed
enough to understand the implications of
their own actions truth be told most
critics bring nothing to the table
they simply project their own
insecurities and add zero value to the
conversation and if we listen to them
their toxicity permeates our thoughts
making it difficult to create anything
worthwhile so you have two choices
either create and be criticized or hide
from meaningful work because you're
scared of a little bird poop personally
I'd rather cover my head and craft
something worth criticizing and Ryan I
think that's that's really what we're
doing now is we really open ourselves up
to the world we have effect but by
having an audience in front of us when
we first started and had 52 people show
them to the blog or now where it's
approaching 5 million people and the
podcast is approaching a million people
we have a sign here that says criticize
me and I think the thing is we want to
delineate between good criticism and bad
criticism here but I I don't know about
you but for me I tend to lean on people
that I care about and whose opinions I
trust and it's why I'll call and I'll
ask you what do you think about this or
with Sean if I'm writing hey hey Sean
can you tell me about about this
sentence or how do you think do you
think this story really strikes a chord
and what would you change about this
because these are opinions that I
appreciate and then also when we are
a book will go out to a whole bunch of
alpha readers and the beta readers and
asked for people who are willing to give
us criticism up front but do so in a in
a meaningful helpful articulate way as
opposed to people who just become
seagulls and fly over and and [ __ ] on so
what's the last whether it was in
regards to the minimalists or your
personal life what's the last good
criticism you got I think I get it from
from you all the time but wait a minute
I criticize you well no I think so but
but I ask for it from you and I think I
think that's that's what's different we
you and I talk about stuff all the time
and I think criticism can be as easy as
I would do it this way but here's why
and that's why it's good it's not it's
the opposite of what bad criticism is
bad criticism is I don't like that that
is stupid you are wrong I'm so
disappointed in your opinion okay but
that doesn't tell me why it's bad and
it's not helpful so good criticism
usually it's helpful and and that comes
from when someone's intentions are good
and they're not just lashing out they're
not having this this fake outrage
finally here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hi my name
is Gabriel
I'm calling from Alexandria Virginia and
I was just calling to share some kind of
fun stories I just randomly started
listening to your podcast about a week
ago
and it was so immediately struck by the
need to simplify my life so some of
those stories I am this weekend clean
about 50% of the stuff I am out of my
apartment and some of the fun things
that happen was one I sound like every
single thing that I've ever thought I'd
lost including clothes that I had bought
and then immediately thought I've lost I
found them in the bottom of my closet um
it was kind of eye-opening like wow I
didn't realize I was kind of a hoarder
also I just felt this huge weight lifted
off me I gave all the stuff to my
parents to go through first in case they
wanted anything and I was able to
immediately
meet some of the needs that they had in
their life since they're not wealthy and
there are some things that I was hanging
on to that I didn't need that were able
to be there for them and items that they
were really get some value from so that
was a huge blessing to me and then after
the weekend we we were on a shopping
chest looking for something for my mom
and I realized that since taking this
little journey walking through the mall
was never going to be the same again
you know just walking by the store and
seeing all this stuff and I'm like wow
remember the days when I thought I
needed this stuff is like literally 24
hours ago so it was just it's amazing
how much my mind has already been
reshaped by the idea that I don't need
all of the things I've been socialized
and advertised to say that I need and
I'm really pushing the stuff out of my
life so that I can make room to do
things that I think are truly important
and I'm going to be able to spend more
of my time and resources
are the things that actually reflect my
values my name is see like the letter
and I have a comment I noticed you guys
had mentioned mister money mustache from
the episode on money I find a lot of
crossover between the minimalist podcast
and the financial independence or early
retirement philosophy which is about how
to make sure that you're spending your
money and your time on things that
really matter in life like relationships
or passions so I would recommend for
listeners of this podcast to check out
the book your money or your life
preferably from a library I think it's a
great resource for people who are
struggling my finding meaning in this
world of consumerism and fancier and
fancier consumer goods hi my name is
Michelle and from Edmonton Alberta
Canada I just have a comment about the
recent health podcast and I just want to
say that one thing that I have found has
been really helpful for me with
increasing my fitness in kind of like a
minimalist way
has been basically making my body a
vehicle you know I live in an Edmonton
Alberta so we have winters and summers
and falls and you know I I used to rely
on my car a lot just to get me
everywhere whereas now I in the summer
time pretty much from April 1 to October
31 weather permits and in the winter I
take the bus and that has made a huge
difference for me because I get some
type of physical exercise every single
day and what I love about cycling in the
summer is just the mental health that I
gain as well because I see the Sun Rise
every morning and I get to experience
nature and I just even if I'm having a
really busy work or family life I don't
feel like I'm missing out on decision
because I'm cycling I'm getting outdoors
every day and and the best part about
that is is for my daughter because she
is a part of that and and she loves
going for bike rides with mommy and she
loves going to stroller rides in the
winter or going for sleigh rides to
daycare every morning and you know so
it's become a real family affair
all right y'all that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine and
if you leave here with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'd
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta hang
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grin oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your tea
[Music]